ورغم البعد الجغرافي الصداقه الصينيه
العربيه ممتده لالاف السنين والتواصل
التاريخي القديم وسجل رسميا في اسرتها
الصينيه التي حكمت عام 202 قبل الميلاد
اما دبلوماسيا وسياسيا فلسطين الجديد التي
تاسست عام
حافظت على الاتصال الوثيق مع دول الشرق
الاوسط
وعلامتها 71 عاما تعمقه الثقه السياسيه
بين العرب والصينيين بانشاء مصر عام
علاقات دبلوماسيه
لتلتحق بعد ذلك ست دول عربيه هي سوريا
والعراق واليمن والمغرب والجزائر والسودان
وضل الدعم السياسي المتبادل ركيزه
الاساسيه للعلاقات وكانت الصين متحمسه
للقضايا العربيه فكان موقفها واضحا من
الاعتداء الذي شدته بريطانيا وفرنسا
واسرائيل ضد مصر حرب السويس عام 1956
وكانت اول دوله غير عربيه تعترف بالحكومه
المؤقته للجمهوريه الجزائريه عام
1958 وايضا كانت اول دوله غير عربيه تعترف
بمنظمه التحرير الفلسطينيه
واقترحت غير مره مبادرات بشان قضيه
الفلسطينيه الاسرائيليه والاتفاق النووي
الايراني وامن الخليج والازمه السوريه
وغيرها من المواقف الداعمه للدول العربيه
في المقابل كانت دعم العربي للصين في كافه
المحافل الدوليه كبيرا ايضا في الدول
العربيه رفعت اصواتها الداعمه للصين مرارا
وتكرارا في مجلس حقوق الانسان التابع
للامم المتحده في القضايا التي تتعلق
بشينجان والتبت وهم كونغ وغيرها
ميس الحربي العربي العربيه